für E-Autos müssen Kinder arbeiten sie
verursachen super viel CO2 und sind
sowieso für Normalverdiener kaum
bezahlbar das Denken zumindest viele
aber stimmt das alles wirklich wir sind
für dieses Video wieder einmal ganz tief
in alle wichtigen Fragen eingetaucht um
heute die größten Mythen über E-Autos
ein für alle Mal aufzuklären was ist
richtig was ist veraltet und was haben
sich elektrogegner einfach nur
ausgedacht und eins vorne weg egal was
hier bei diesem Video rauskommt eins
steht heute schon fest e-Autos sind die
Zukunft das ist in der Industrie
mittlerweile eindeutig klar auch wenn im
Verbrenner aus Ausnahmen für e-fuels
festgehalten wurden will kaum ein
Hersteller nach 2035 noch Verbrenner
produzieren und das wurde schon vor dem
Verbrenner aus entschieden die
Elektrifizierung unserer PKW ist keine
Zukunftsmusik mehr sondern das was jetzt
gerade passiert die Hersteller machen
Ernst also was kommt da auf uns
zu
dr Watson live aus der Zukunft so heißt
meine livehow und ich komme
wahrscheinlich auch auf eine Bühne in
deiner Nähe mich wird es mega freuen
Euch zu sehen und es wird da auch um
E-Autos gehen tickets gibt es unten in
der Videobeschreibung heute geht es
darum ob E-Autos wirklich so teuer sind
ob sie für die Umwelt tatsächlich besser
sind wo der Strom dafür herkommen soll
wie die Rohstoffe gewonnen werden und
jetzt vielleicht die wichtigste Frage
für den Alltag vieler wie weit komme ich
damit
eigentlich hier hört man ja oft sowas
hier gestern berichtet die Nachbarin
nach einer Fahrt nach Berlin dass sie
jetzt ohne Radio und Klimaanlage fährt
da sonst die Batterie zu schnell leer
wird behauptet zumindest dr Verbrenner
auf Twitter und dann muss es ja stimmen
andere meinen erstens wer soll das
bezahlen zweitens wie lange dauert es um
wirklich eine funktionierende
Infrastruktur aufzubauen drittens was
machen die Leute in einer Innenstadt die
in einem Hochhaus wohnen okay kommen wir
mal zu den Fakten theoretisch können
einige E-Autos über 600 kilomet mit
einer einzigen Ladung fahren z.B
erreicht der Mercedes-Benz IQs bis zu
770 km und der chinesische Hersteller
Neo will den et7 bald auf 1000 km
Reichweite bringen in der Praxis fällt
die Reichweite oft niedriger aus vor
allem im Winter bei aufgedrehter
Klimaanlage oder auf der Autobahn das
Radio hat übrigens keinen großen Effekt
aber immerhin gibt es mit dem wltp Wert
eine Größe mit der man verschiedene
E-Autos vergleichen kann und sind mal
ehrlich bei den spritangaben für
Verbrenner sieht das nicht besser aus
der icct vergleicht verschiedene
Datenquellen und kommt fürs Jahr 2017
auf einen durchschnittlich 39% höheren
Spritverbrauch als angegeben h in einer
Umfrage wurden die Sorgen von
e-autokäufern ermittelt 73% davon
nannten die Reichweite 60% das Laden auf
langen Strecken nach 3 Jahren würden
sich jetzt 98% von Ihnen wieder ein
E-Auto kaufen ich übrigens nach vi
Jahren E-Auto fahren auch Reichweite und
Langstreckentauglichkeit sind für 99 bzw
95 % kein Problem oder wenigstens mit
Gewöhnung okay dreiviertel treten
längere Strecken ohne Bedenken an neben
der größeren Reichweite ist aber auch
die Ladeinfrastruktur entscheidend dann
kommt man auch mit kleinem Akku oder im
Winter überall hin und hier hat sich in
den letzten Jahren richtig viel getan
die Anzahl der Ladepunkte hat sich seit
2017 mehr als
verzehnfacht seit 2021 mehr als
verdoppelt und das Aufladen geht auch
immer schneller im letzten Jahr ist
insbesondere die Zahl der
schnelladepunkte gewachsen darunter
fällt alles mit einer Ladeleistung über
22 kW und klar wirklich schnell ist das
noch nicht aber über 60% der
schnelladepunkte bieten Leistungen von
149 kW und aufwärts und das ist
tatsächlich schon ziemlich zackig auch
wenn Temperatur und Ladestand die
Ladeleistung beeinträchtigen gibt es
immer mehr Modelle die den Akku vor dem
Laden aufheizen und so z.B in 30 Minuten
300 km und mehr aufladen oder wie wir in
unserer Doku über E-Autos knapp 100 km
in 5 Minuten womit man direkt wieder
eine Stunde Autobahn fahren kann Neo
bietet übrigens auch jetzt schon
regelmäßige Akkuwechsel an in den man
statt den Akku zu laden das Auto in eine
Station fährt wo die Batterie durch eine
andere geladene ersetzt wird in Europa
ist das noch keine Alternative zum Laden
aber in China gibt es bereits über 1200
dieser Stationen okay war's das ach nee
wie ist das denn jetzt für Stadtbewohner
aus meiner eigenen Erfahrung kann ich
sagen das ist tatsächlich der Punkt
gewesen der mich am meisten gestört hat
wer nicht regelmäßig am Supermarkt zu
Hause oder auf der Arbeit laden kann
muss stattdessen tatsächlich tanken
fahren und das nervt hier müssen wir
noch mehr Ladestation bauen und zwar da
wo man regelmäßig mal eine Stunde oder
so parkt aber mit besserer
Ladeinfrastruktur und großen Akkus hat
man eine echt gute
Reichweite da gibt es nur einen Haken
größere Akkus brauchen halt auch mehr
Rohstoffe und da kommen wir zum nächsten
Punkt bestimmt hast du auch schon mal
das hier gehört dann kommen dazu Zutaten
für die Batterien wie Litium ja das
unter entsetzlichen Bedingungen in Peru
abgebaut wird grauenhaft wenn sie sich
angucken Kinderarbeit und so weiter
Sklavenarbeit da werden diese kommen die
Zutaten für diese Batterien her in
vielen e-Autos sind Metalle enthalten
die teuer und schwierig abzubauen oder
ethisch fragwürdig sind z.B Kobalt die
nach Frage steigt stetig nach Angaben
des Cobalt Institute wurden 2021 34%
oder 59 000 Tonnen und damit der größte
Teil des Global verwendeten kobalts für
E-Autos eingesetzt und Kobalt wird von
vielen direkt mit Kinderarbeit und
schlechten Arbeitsbedingungen in
Verbindung gebracht auch litiium oder
Lithium wie die Chemiker sagen ist nicht
unproblematisch weil es in fast allen
Akkus eingesetzt wird steigt der Bedarf
natürlich von 2016 auf 2022 hat sich der
Abbau verdreifacht Litium ist zwar
reichlich vorhanden aber verteilt die
Gewinnung durch die Austrocknung von
Sole kann zu Problemen bei der
Wasserversorgung führen neben Litium und
Kobalt werden auch noch weitere
potenziell kritische Rohstoffe verwendet
wie Metalle der Seltenen Erden die
übrigens nicht für die Akkus oder Nickel
unproblematisch sind sie alle nicht aber
erstens werden diese Rohstoffe nicht nur
in Batterien für Elektroautos verwendet
sondern auch in allen anderen möglichen
Geräten wie Smartphones Laptops oder
Kopfhörern oder in der Industrie
wir müssen uns bewusst machen dass jede
Form von Konsum die Umwelt belastet
durch die Kritik am E-Auto sind die
Missstände in der Rohstoffbeschaffung
endlich in der Öffentlichkeit angekommen
was mega gut und wichtig ist aber das
bedeutet eben nicht dass andere Produkte
besser sind und auch nicht dass wir
keine E-Autos bauen sollten zweitens
muss man die Auswirkungen auch in
Perspektive setzen der Wasserverbrauch
für das Litium in einem typischen
e-autoakku ist nur ungefähr so groß wie
der einer halben Jeans das meiste Litium
stammt sowieso aus dem Tagebau in
Australien indem das Metall ohne
Wasserverschwendung gewonnen wird
außerdem entstehen auch weitere Projekte
in Europa unter anderem das weltweit
erste Zero Carbon Lithium und Rohstoffe
sind für viele Exportländer auch einfach
eine wirtschaftliche Chance nicht die
Verwendung an sich ist das Problem
sondern die Gewinnung drittens hat sich
auch hier in den letzten Jahren einiges
getan schon 2021 hat der chinesische
Batteriehersteller svolt den ersten
kobaltfreien serienreifen E-Auto Aku
vorgestellt und auch Tesla ist mit an
Bord knapp die Hälfte der Autos die im
ersten Quartal 2022 produziert wurden
kommt schon komplett ohne Kobalt aus
weil litiium eisenfosphatakkus verwendet
werden auch BYD setzt auf LFP
Technologie es geht sogar komplett ohne
Litium in Natrium ionenakkus wird
stattdessen ich glaube ihr könnt es euch
denken Natrium verwendet das quasi
unbegrenzt verfügbar und damit viel
günstiger und nachhaltiger ist damit
kommt dieser Akkutyp ohne Litium ohne K
und ohne Kupfer aus buid verwendet
diesen Akkutyp schon allerdings bekommt
man den Seal bisher nur in China die
Hersteller haben die rohstoffprobleme
also auf dem Schirm und es ist gerade in
ihrem wirtschaftlichen Interesse
günstigere und nachhaltige Batterien zu
produzieren viel Hoffnung ruht auch auf
der feststoffbatterie aber jeder
Batterietyp hat vor und Nachteile Kosten
Energiedichte oder Produktionskapazität
wenn die berücksichtigt werden können in
Zukunft alle mobilitätsnischen abgedeckt
werden trotzdem muss ich in einem Punkt
noch viel tun Recycling da die Akkus oft
länger halten als die Autos in denen sie
verbaut sind was vielen übrigens oft
ganz anders erzählt wurde erleben Sie
ein Second Life z.B als heimspeicher und
danach könnten ausgediente Akkus eine
wertvolle Quelle für neue Rohstoffe
werden für die nächsten Jahre sind viele
tausende Tonnen Kapazität fürs Recycling
angekündigt bei den Anlagen die es heute
schon gibt handelt es sich nach
Experteneinschätzungen aber eher um
Testanlagen weil es bisher noch nicht
genug ausgediente Akkus gibt in Zukunft
werden die Batterien übrigens noch
grüner im EU-Parlament wurde im Juni ein
Gesetz verabschiedet das den kompletten
Lebenszyklus der Batterien
berücksichtigt von der
Rohstoffbeschaffung bis zum Recycling ab
Juli 2024 muss dadurch der gesamte
Fußabdruck der Batterie angegeben werden
ab 2027 soll ein CO2 Höchstwert für
Batterien festgelegt werden außerdem
wurden recyclingziele für verschiedene
Rohstoffe beschlossen theoretisch lassen
sich schon heute fast alle Rohstoffe aus
den Batterien recyceln beim Verbrenner
sind am Ende der Lebensdauer einfach 17
000 l Sprit weg bzw sie sind dann
Treibhausgase und verschmutzte Luft bis
wir ein so umfassendes Recycling haben
gibt es aber noch ein paar
Herausforderungen Logistik ausreichende
Mengen an Batterien und viel grüner
Strom Stichwort Strom dazu gibt es
gleich mehrere
myth z.B wird immer wieder behauptet
dass das Stromnetz nicht für E-Autos
ausgelegt sei so wie hier oder Headlines
wie Wärmepumpen Solaranlagen E-Autos
warum das Stromnetz an seine Grenzen
kommt aber stimmt das wirklich in einem
Experiment von Netze BW wurden 10
E-Autos an Bewohner einer Straße
vergeben die alle am gleichen Stromkreis
hängen damit hatte dieses Gebiet eine
Quote von 50% E-Autos deutlich mehr als
wir aktuell in Deutschland haben durch
die unterschiedlichen Tagesabläufe haben
nie mehr als fünf Autos gleichzeitig
geladen und selbst das nur 0,1% der Zeit
es Laden also nie alle Menschen
gleichzeitig ihr E-Auto und deswegen
wird das Stromnetz nicht so sehr
belastet wie es vielleicht am Anfang den
Schein hat jetzt werden größere Projekte
entwickelt die ganze Viertel abdecken
schon 201 2019 hat außerdem eine Studie
aus der Industrie ergeben dass das
Stromnetz schon damals bereit für 45
Millionen E-Autos gewesen sei und das
ohne Ausbau des Netzes einzige
Voraussetzung ein intelligentes
Lademanagement das ist aber auch aus
anderen Gründen eine super Idee denn in
Zukunft sollen E-Autos unser Stromnetz
entlasten statt es zu belasten indem die
Batterien als Stromspeicher genutzt
werden und so Schwankungen der
erneuerbaren Energien ausgleichen und
genau das könnt ihr schon heute machen
mit tippber das ist ein besonders
smarter Ökostromanbieter der sich dem
Mythos der Netzüberlastung angenommen
hat und die Schwankungen im Stromnetz
nutzt um günstige Preise an seine Kunden
weiterzugeben und das ohne
Gewinnmarge eine Grundgebühr von 4,49 €
im Monat gibt tippber die an der
Strombörse gehandelten Marktpreise
einfach an euch weiter das bedeutet
immer wenn der Börsenstrompreis gerade
niedrig ist spart ihr Geld ladet ihr
euer E-Auto also in der Nacht wo
gewöhnlich wenig Strom verbraucht wird
dann ist der Strom auch günstiger und
manchmal gibt es sogar Zeiten wo ihr
dank tippber pro verbrauchter
Kilowattstunde Geld verdient in
Skandinavien ist es aktuell sogar schon
möglich seine e-autobatterie mit dem
Netz zu teilen damit hilft man die Netz
Auslastung zu regulieren und kann bald
sogar Geld damit verdienen das könnte
auch in Deutschland Realität werden die
Smart charging Funktion von titimber
steht euch aber jetzt schon zur
Verfügung und nimmt euch das
Micromanagement eures Stromverbrauchs ab
ladezeitpunkt und Ladedauer eures
E-Autos werden damit automatisch
optimiert damit könnt ihr bis zu 18 %
eurer Stromkosten einsparen mit dem Link
in der Videobeschreibung und dem Code
Watson könnt ihr euch ganz einfach bei
Tiber anmelden und direkt einen 50 €
Gutschein für den Tiber store sichern
damit unterstützt natürlich auch noch
uns und unsere Videos danke dafür und
jetzt geht's weiter mit unseren Mythen
bleiben wir beim Strom wir können mit
der Elektromobilität nichts für den
Klimaschutz tun wenn wir Kohlestrom zum
Laden
nutzen aber dieser Strom ist nicht grün
sondern er ist schmutzig das elektraauto
fährt mit kohlestr 60% der Befragten
bezweifeln in einer Allensbach Umfrage
dass Elektroautos umweltfreundlicher
sind einige Kritiker behaupten E-Autos W
würden als zusätzliche Verbraucher nur
Kohlestrom Verfahren und seien damit
nicht
klimafreundlicher mit dieser
grenzstromrechnung mehr dazu übrigens in
diesem Video hier gibt es aber gleich
mehrere Probleme erstens nur weil
E-Autos neue Verbraucher sind haben sie
nicht weniger anricht auf grünen Strom
sie sind nicht mehr für Kohlestrom im
Netz verantwortlich als Kühlschränke
Trockner oder Föns zweitens in
Deutschland besitzen laut einer Umfrage
vom Frauenhofer Isi fast die Hälfte der
Haushalte mit E-Auto eine eigene
PV-Anlage 84% besitzen einen
ökostromvertrag deutlich mehr als im
Bevölkerungsdurchschnitt man könnte also
sagen dass E-Autos den Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren gerade im kleinen
unterstützen drittens Laden E-Autos
nicht nur in windstillen Nächten sondern
das ganze Jahr über man kann ihre nutzen
fürs Klima nicht an einigen Tagen Messen
an denen durch die E-Autos ein
Kohlekraftwerk mehr angeworfen wird wie
schon gesagt könnten E-Autos als
zusätzlicher Speicher die
Stromschwankungen der Erneuerbaren sogar
ausgleichen und damit dafür sorgen dass
wir weniger abhängig von fossilen werden
2021 und 2022 ist durch die
wirtschaftliche Erholung nach Corona
sowohl der grünstromanteil gesunken als
auch die CO2 Menge pro Kilowattstunde
angestiegen erstmal schlecht aber selbst
wenn das E-Auto mit diesem schlechten
Strommix von 2021 betrieben wird
emitiert es in der Nutzung immer noch
nur die Hälfte im Vergleich zum
Verbrenner aber relevanter als der
stromix heute ist ja eigentlich der
Strommix der Zukunft ein Verbrenner
emitiert für jeden gefahrenen Kilometer
gleich viel egal ob jetzt oder in 20
Jahren ein E-Auto hingegen profitiert
von mehr erneuerbaren Energien die in
Zukunft ans Netz kommen in einer
globalen Analyse hat das icct die CO2
Emissionen über den gesamten
Lebenszyklus untersucht nach diesen
Zahlen erreicht ein europäischer
kompaktklassewagen der 2021 zugelassen
wurde einen emissionsvorteil von 66 bis
69%. 2030 und und mit erneuerbarem Strom
sind sogar
81%. aber ich bin sicher dass es nicht
halbar ist weil der Kunde nicht mitpielt
dieses
Massenverkehrsmittel wird es nie werden
und da zahle ich eben gut mal 6 60 70 80
000 € oder sogar noch mehr gut dann lass
uns über Geld reden grundsätzlich werden
E-Autos in der Anschaffung immer
günstiger der Umweltbonus wurde zwar
gesenkt aber 2023 gibt es immer noch
6000 750 € beim Kauf eines E-Autos von
unter 40.000 €. in diesem Jahr haben
Tesla und andere Hersteller schon
mehrfach Rabatte von mehreren Taus Euro
angeboten und je mehr Elektroautos auf
den Markt kommen desto mehr gibt es auch
auf dem Gebrauchtmarkt aber dazu kommen
natürlich noch Sprit oder Strom parken
Versicherung Förderungen und so weiter
in Untersuchungen in denen die Total
Cost of Ownership also die sogenannten
Vollkosten betrachtet werden liegen
E-Autos nach einiger Zeit meist vor den
Verbrennern die die E-Autos fahren ihre
höheren Anschaffungskosten also wieder
ein wie lange das dauert ist allerdings
je nach Fahrzeugklasse unterschiedlich
für SUV und Mittelklasse Wagen ist das
schon nach ungefähr 3 Jahren der Fall
für kleinere Wagen dauert es länger das
liegt daran dass sich viele Hersteller
wegen der höheren Gewinnmarge auf
teurere oder größere Wagen
spezialisieren und die
Anschaffungskosten im Vergleich zum
Verbrenner bisher relativ hoch ausfallen
im Vergleich zum Benziner Kleinwagen
gibt es selbst bei langer Haltedauer
kaum einen Vorteil in China sind solche
e-kleinwagen schon deutlich günstiger zu
haben wenn chinesische Hersteller wie
BYD diese Modelle auch in Europa
anbieten besteht also die Hoffnung dass
sich das ändert ein paar kleinere
Ersparnisse gibt es aber trotzdem noch
mit dem E-Kennzeichen ist das Parken in
vielen Städten gebührenfrei teilweise
gibt es Förderungen für eigene wallboxen
und Hinweise auf weniger Pannen über den
gesamten Lebenszyklus berechnet der ADAC
für die meisten E-Autos zum Teil
deutlich geringere Kosten obwohl der
Anschaffungspreis tendenziell höher
liegt
[Musik]
okay was bedeutet das jetzt alles in
meinen Augen ist die Sache klar E-Autos
starten durch die Batterie mit einem
höheren Fußabdruck in ihr Leben aber
während der Lebensdauer gleicht sich das
durch die höhere Effizienz wieder aus
dabei profitieren E-Autos von einem
steigenden grünstromanteil und zwar
jetzt und in der Zukunft noch mehr das
ist weltweit bei der Förderung von
Rohstoffen Konflikte gibt ist nicht neu
aber das passiert eben nicht nur für
E-Autos trotzdem muss ich da auf jeden
Fall etwas tun das lieferkettengesetz
ist ein Anfang aber wir brauchen noch
mehr Siegel für Rohstoffe und ihre
Förderung ein besseres Recycling oder
eben Akkus ohne konfliktrohstoffe seit
unserer letzten Doku zum Thema die euch
gerne hier angucken könnt ist nur noch
eindeutiger geworden dass E-Autos die
Zukunft sind durch höhere Reichweiten
und ein immer besseres Ladenetz sind
E-Autos definitiv
alltagstauglich abstriche muss man
eventuell bei den Anschaffungskosten
machen und wenn man keine Möglichkeit
hat regelmäßig da zu Laden wo man
sowieso schon ist aber und das ist mir
wichtig zu sagen E-Autos werden das
Klima nicht retten und das hat den
einfachen Grund dass Autos an sich schon
schlecht sind Mobilität mit Fahrrad Bus
und Bahn ist oft günstiger gesünder und
vor allem umweltfreundlicher aber falls
man tatsächlich auf ein Auto angewiesen
ist auf das man auf keinen Fall
verzichten kann führt vor allem in der
Zukunft kein Weg am elektrischen fahren
vorbei wie immer vielen lieben Dank fürs
zuschauen und bleibt neugierig euer
Crick